Welcome, pilgrims. You traveled far beyond your fun entertainment videos.
You've come to the right place, hooray! A lot of laughter awaits you.
This is the "Channel Awesome" youtube channel!
Here you can see our classic material, look! Also new material.
"Vandal Review", "Ask the Glass Guy", "Video Game Confession", Annual Specials, "How to Make" Nostalgia Critic!
Don't be mistaken! There's enough.
Classic videos, new material!
Yes Youtube. Now you can make yourself happy.
Youtube Channel Channel Awesome!
Watch him ... they don't give anything else now.
So, except for "Red vs. Blue", that's pretty good.
In fact, "Honest Trailers", they're pretty funny,
"How it Should've Ended" is just perfect
"Cinema Sins", they can make me laugh every time
Oh, hey, hey, "BrentalFloss", he's great, why don't you look at him?
God, "Angry Video Game Nerd", gentlemen, I'm not telling that much to people, but he's just great ...
(Embarrassed) Click on the videos.
Juhu!